hey guys Pete here gonna be looking at
mr. robot season 3 stuff today this
teaser isn't actually new it's surfaced
on the mr. robot Facebook page a few
days ago but they added a higher
resolution version on their YouTube
channel yesterday it's a short one but
there's a bunch of frames in there you
could miss if you're watching it in real
time I decided not to add the teaser
itself here because as you know if
you've ever tried to watch mystery robot
stuff outside of the US they have a
really strange blocking policy I don't
understand it completely but their
trailers you know trailers are always
free to use under fair use but because
of the way they use their show promotion
they must have some weird distribution
rights in different countries so they
block both of my last two season 3
trailer breakdowns in various countries
so we're just gonna stick to the stills
instead also stick around into the end
because I'm doing a rewatch for season 1
I'll tell you about and making videos
about that the trailer starts with
Elliott sitting in what appears to be
Krista's office we assume it is her
office because the voice-over is Christa
and she's doing some sort of relaxation
hypnosis hypnotherapy I don't know
exactly how to describe it she starts
out saying Elliott I'd like you to close
your eyes we see him do that he's
sitting in front of a bookshelf which I
say that it appears to be her office
because in previous episodes we've never
actually seen these books she has two
smaller bookshelves in her office in
season one and as far as I can remember
she still had those and all the scenes
we've seen there Elliott has always been
seated on the couch in front of the
windows as well but whatever is
happening hypnosis wise it seems to be
coming in a meeting with her she says
why don't you sit back and relax and we
see the door sequence from the II Corp
headquarters from the previous trailers
we see him coming out of the revolving
door looking like what I would call
bewildered without much more context
then there's a cut to him taking his
medication and putting the bottle back
we can tell that it's cetera lien which
is a garden-variety antidepressant that
is sold under the brand name zoloft in
the US and it can also be used for PTSD
and anxiety disorders she continues
let's take a moment listen to the sound
of my voice in the ferris wheel at Coney
Island we find Elliott talking to mr.
robot
mr. robots clothing here is different
than when we first saw them together in
the ferris wheel scene so it's not a
flashback to the first time Elliott
visited the arcade it could very well be
a flashback though we just don't have
any other indication of when this
happens after that it cuts to Tyrell
who's sitting in front of what looks
like an elevator door and then we get a
sort of blast of scenes in quick
succession we see the policemen in riot
gear get hit in the head with a bottle
then a shot of Tyrell yelling in front
of a terminal with Angela sitting next
to him and Darlene being thrown against
the wall in the FBI interview room by
who I assume is Santiago it's worth
mentioning that it continually cuts back
to Elliott sitting on the couch with his
eyes closed in between all this stuff
I'm just not gonna repeat that every
single time it happens this could be an
indication that he is remembering these
things but he isn't physically present
in all of the scenes as far as we can
tell the voiceover continues now take a
deep breath Elliot and Darlene are in
his apartment which we've seen from
previous trailers and we guess that they
are trying to stop stage 2 then there is
an interesting sequence it starts out
with Elliot grabbing Darlene as it looks
like she's trying to leave the apartment
he pushes her against the wall and while
this is happening we see a change over
to mr. robot at the end it's mr. robot
that has her pinned against the wall so
this could be more of that glitching
that we saw in season 2 from that we get
another look at Elliot flying against
the wall this is probably similar to
when he was fighting with mr. robot on
season 2 since you don't see anyone
there with him and
was coming out of an office and her eye
makeup is smeared from crying
it looks like the floodlights are
flashing where she is and we get a
better indication of where this is later
the voice-over continues I think this
will help you
Dom shows up with gun drawn again which
we've seen and it cuts to Darlene
approaching what looks like someone's
front door with Dom walking behind her I
talked about this in my previous trailer
breakdown and there isn't any extra
added footage here after that there's a
sequence of hand shots the first one is
drilling out a hard drive and that one
cuts to a hand clicking on a mouse
they're both shots of hands and they
don't look like the same hands the one
clicking the mouse looks a lot more
slender to me and it could be the same
as Elliot's hands which we see next on
the keyboard after that after the
keyboard we see someone using a keycard
to pass through a turnstile the keycard
looks like a work idea or badge so this
could be entering the e-court building
it's really quick though and not all
that clear so we're using contextual
clues here to guess that he's going into
the building that we see him come out of
later it goes back to Elliot on the
couch and then we see the popcorn
machine from Coney Island gets smashed
looks like Elliot's hoodie and it looks
like he's just smashing the glass with a
bare fist and there also may be someone
standing off to the right but I can't
tell for sure there's a quick cut to
Joana wellick riding in what looks like
her SUV we see the security guard at
eeek or struggling with the protesters
again in the lobby then there's a shot
of Elliot going into his apartment
walking up the front steps as soldiers
are walking by on the street there's a
shot of Irving who's played by Bobby
Cannavale character at the bottom of a
set of stairs nothing to actually say
where this is the unidentified person
wearing the F Society mass shows up
again we saw a longer look at this in
one of the social media teasers they put
out so we know that there are agents
rushing into the room but
we don't know who it is or where it is
there's a quick flash to fill a price
and Tyrell in the latter's apartment I
mentioned the timeline on this and it's
confusing but it seems like it would be
a flashback another shot of Elliott with
his hand in front of his face standing
in front of the red books on the shelf
again we don't know exactly where this
one is we get Angela who looks like
she's wearing the same clothes that she
was wearing in the shop where she had
been crying only in this shot she's
wearing the smear Deaf society mask this
could be blood on the mask it could be
something else but we've seen this
before
it looks like Elliott is running behind
her but there's also a third person and
I have no idea who they are
she's clearly standing in front of an E
Court plaque on the wall so that gives
us confirmation that all these things
are in Ecore offices and they look to be
overrun with all the spray-paint damage
on the walls so this could be the
headquarters post when we see the
scuffle outside or it could be something
else you know I mean we really can't say
for sure but outside the elevator you
can definitely see there's an e core
plaque on the wall so it's in one of
their buildings there's a shot of
someone who looks like Elliott smashing
a fire extinguisher through a window and
a door they could have an F Society mask
on here but I'm not exactly sure there's
someone I don't recognize at all on the
other side doing what I have no idea
they could be hiding they could be
waiting it out something like that on
the door there's a sign with red shoes
or more precisely ruby slippers and when
you zoom in it says there's no place
like and then there's an IP address
which is one two seven zero zero one now
that is a looping IP address that's used
for the local machine it's a reference
to the Wizard of Oz I don't know if this
is an indication that this is a dream it
kind of feels that way to me though I
mean you can't really think of too many
places where you would see this sign up
in an official capacity but it would
make sense and say a dream elliott was
having but you know the other stuff
doesn't really jive I mean I don't
no it's pretty mysterious at this point
then the voice-over finishes off by
Krista saying Elliot as a question and
we see him open his eyes and we see him
open his eyes to end the trailer so
there's a lot of interesting stuff here
and I think what I come away with the
most and it relates to something that
Sam Esmail said was that there's going
to be a confusing timeline in season 3 I
mean it may make total sense but SML
said that they're gonna be telling
things in a circular fashion like
filling in details from the past that's
a paraphrase but that's the way that I
interpreted what he said and so I think
that some of this stuff would be
flashback related obviously breaking the
popcorn machine is one of the most
interesting things and that could tie in
to what he said about in a month from
now we'll be talking about that one
scene we may actually get the look into
those three days during the five nine
hack that Elliot can't remember the
Ecore building being overrun is a pretty
big question mark I guess um and we
don't expect that people won't fight
back in the situation that they're in
but I mean the damage that we see and
the fact that the flood lights are
flashing and there's smoke and some of
these scenes is that in the same
building some major event is going to
happen against Ecore proper is that
stage - well we know stage 2 is
basically supposed to bring a building
down so it's not necessarily related but
I'm sure it's all tied together in one
way or the other they did release
another short teaser yesterday as well
and it's a it's a just a montage of old
things basically but it's Elliott saying
that he found a way to undo - hit undo
and then we see a rewind of all these
events that happen in previous seasons
and it looks like it's foreshadowing the
fact that he's going to try to undo the
damage caused by the 5/9 hack I decided
not to make a specific breakdown for
that yet because it might be a part of
something else and they have been
throwing out a lot of interesting stuff
on their Twitter and Facebook accounts
leading up so at the very least I'll
probably do a trailer
cap of all the different things that
they've been putting out there but I
didn't want to make a separate video for
each one however I do think this close
your eyes thing is pretty important and
it leads to questions about is Christa
on Elliott's side I tend to think that
she is I tend to think that she's trying
to help him he's obviously trying to
block out mr. robot but he's also trying
to remember things that have happened
that he did as mr. robot and can't
remember so I think in general I think
that intentions are good there it also
brings up the idea that I've seen a lot
of people talking about that Santiago is
likely in bed with the dark army and
that Dom may be going rogue in that
scene where we see her sort of an you
know on her own with the gun now there
are several different reasons that that
to think that I won't go into all of
them here but one of the biggest ones is
the stuff that happened in China and
then we also had whenever Cisco when he
wanted to make Cisco's identity public I
mean those things could be influenced by
a connection with the dark army for sure
could be straight tinfoil as well but
somehow I think DOM is a good guy even
though she works for the FBI so I think
there will be some graying you know like
I think she'll be working outside of the
FBI framework at some point so let me
know what you think have you been
following all this stuff like where's
your head at for season three right now
I think that this shows that there may
be some dreams as well as some actual
flashbacks which is interesting a show
that's built on mystery is it's good if
we get some answers what's your favorite
clip here I thought that it you know the
idea of seeing him glitch when he's when
he's going against Darlene is is
interesting also when I first saw it I
didn't notice that Angela was in the
scene with Tyrell where he's screaming
at the computer so we did kind of see
her in there with Bobby or Irving I
should say so yeah I'm curious to see
based on we saw Angela crossover kind of
an official sense when she met with what
White Rose but
interested to see if she had more
involvement before that that helped tip
the scales so let me know what you guys
think please make sure you like the
video if you enjoyed it subscribe to my
channel I'm getting ready to go full mr.
robot mode as the season gets started of
course I'll still be doing my other
things but I really love mr. robot and
can't wait to follow this I am also
doing a season 1 rewatch which you can
join along if you want I'm gonna get
videos up for all those episodes since I
don't have them I started mr. robot in
season 2 so I'll be trying to get all
those done in the next couple of weeks
to have them ready before the season
comes out make sure that you check out
my patreon account if you're interested
in helping to keep this thing going
mr. robots not the most popular show so
it doesn't get huge views but I'm
dedicated to do it and I love it so I'm
going to whether it makes good sense
financially or not follow me on social
media you can interact with me over on
Twitter Instagram Facebook and thanks
for watching guys I'll talk to you soon